قرر اعضاء مجلس الاحتياطي ارسال اشاره
مفادها ان مكافحه التضخم ما زالت على راس
اولوياتهم على الرغم من موجه عدم
الاستقرار في القطاع المصرفي صور السجن
واستمر كان قرارنا هو المضي قدما في زياده
مقدارها ربع نقطه مئويه وتغيير توجهاتنا
من سياسه زيادات المستمره ولد فانه سيكون
هناك المزيد من رفع اسعار الفائده استنادا
للبيانات والتطورات ويبدو ان المجلس قرر
ان التضخم هو اخطر ما يتهدد الاقتصاد
الامريكي وان كان الامل في تخفيض نسبته
الى اثنين في المئه قد لا يتحقق في
المستقبل القريب كانت الرساله للاسواق
بانه لم يتوقف عن الرافعه المتوقع حتى لا
يتصور البعض ان الازمه اكبر من مشكله
التضخم هو ما زال يصر ان التضخم هو محاربه
التراكم هي الاولويه الاولى في الوقت
الحالي
كثيرا من الاضطرابات التي حدثت الاسبوعين
الماضيين وللتاكيد على تلك الرساله حاولت
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه طمانه المصارف
والمودعين على حد سواء
اتخذنا اجراءات لحمايه المدعين في
المصرفين المفلسين وتوفير سيوله اضافيه
للبنوك من اجل تخفيف المخاطر على النظام
المصرفي
وتسعى تلك الرساله على ما يبدو الى وقف
المخاوف من كوابيس الازمه الماليه لعام
2008 قرر المسؤولون الامريكيون فتح جبهتين
متزامنتين ضد علل الاقتصاد الامريكي من
رفع اسعار الفائده ضد التضخم الى دعم
المصارف تجنبا لافلاسها على الرغم من
التكلفه المحتمله لذلك ماليا وسياسيا محمد
العلمي الجزيره واشنطن